and then mike there was part b of it
regarding compensation
for teams that entertain and eventually
get more minority candidates to that
step before if not this step of hiring
in the interview process can you
synthesize what the outcome of that
conversation was for everyone
yes it's a reversal from something that
coach and i talked at length about
earlier this year when there was
consideration given to awarding
compensatory draft picks to teams who
hire minority coaches or minority
general managers now the reward goes not
to the team that makes the hire but to
the team that develops the candidate to
the point where he becomes attractive as
a coach or a gm with another team that
team if it employed the minority
candidate for two or more years
gets two third-round draft picks if and
when that person becomes a head coach or
a gm with another team so the incentive
is now to create a robust pipeline of
diverse and inclusive candidates and
coach i've been saying all week they
need to get away from employment at
these lower jobs based on who you know
and who you're related to and this is an
incentive to do that
it really is uh mike and i'm in favor of
this i did some work with the first
pilot alliance and we're kind of working
on tweaking this and it really does make
sense uh we know when you're hiring
people in those entry-level positions a
lot of times it goes to your son or your
nephew if i was there i'd hire my son
obviously uh but when you think about
that now hey i'm gonna hire a quality
control person on offense if i can hire
a young bright minority candidate and
five years from now we're gonna get a
third round draft choice that that might
tip the scale a little bit and cause me
to think well maybe i don't need to hire
the first person i see on this on this
resume sheet or i don't need to hire one
of my relatives let me do something for
the team and then that's gonna help that
pipeline that we all seem to be talking
about
coach i don't know just sitting here
listening and just kind of just thinking
about everything to me it's i'm actually
insulted
because to me it's just insulting to
have to offer incentives for an
organization to hire somebody of color
or a black person and to me if we're
good enough to play on the field we're
good enough to do different things we're
good enough to be able to coach and get
into the front office and go in there
and change some of the policies and
things like that
and that's why it's so important and
that's why we root for raheem morris and
brian flores and mike tomlin that's why
we root for these coaches to have
success because if they don't have
success and they fail that's just
another excuse for the owners to come in
and say well we hired we gave him a
chance but of course the black coach
couldn't make it so that's why every
single week we root for these guys
no no question and that's rodney exactly
why i was kind of against the first uh
iteration we had of this of rewarding
that team that hired the coach because i
think you're absolutely right nobody
wants to come on that level but as you
look back on it i'll take you back to my
career as a coach i come in in 1996 i'm
a young head coach ready to go trying to
hire a staff and i know the problems
that young african americans had getting
started so i hired lovey smith out of
college and i hired herm edwards when he
wasn't in the nfl and i knew that those
guys could do it and they needed to be
in there but somebody who doesn't have
that mindset who doesn't think well gosh
these entry-level positions make a
difference now giving them some
incentive and saying you know what if
you'll at least go out there and
investigate
and look for the best people somewhere
down the road your organization may
benefit so take your time
still hire the best people but you know
what there's some incentive to look
around and i think this is gonna help i
really do
and coach and that's one of the reasons
why i respect you so much and so many
people across the league respect you so
much because you didn't you didn't get
to a point
of success and you said forget about
everyone else you said you know what i'm
going to bring people along i'm going to
use my experience and all the
information that i know i'm going to
teach other people and empower them and
that's why i have so much respect for
you and that's why so many other people
whether it's players coaches scouts they
always talk to me hey tell coach dungeon
said hello because they know what type
of person you are and that's what it's
about ultimately mike tarico
ditto times a thousand couldn't agree
more with what you said rodney can i
just double back to what you were
talking about
the quota systems obviously
get people very uptight and very
concerned on both sides of it nobody
wants token assignments or token jobs
given
but this system hasn't worked
so they got to find something that's
going to work a bit better and i do love
the fact and tony for all the work that
your group did that you helped the fritz
pollard association group do
at least it gives some relatively
intelligent direction to
we are incentivizing you to do this and
to develop i agree you should be doing
it automatically but if the pipeline
doesn't get full with more candidates
people aren't going to get to the top
with a real chance to succeed
so i hear what you're saying i agree
with what you're saying but i also at
the same time think we can applaud
what's being done here because i do
think it's going to give more minorities
a real chance and more importantly
head coaches owners the establishment in
the league which has been largely white
men
the opportunity to develop these guys
and the incentive to develop and guess
what they're going to realize we can
develop anybody who looks in any color
or shape or anything else good tony you
guys say something i'm sorry and mike
yeah i'm gonna interrupt rodney here for
a little bit and just say what hopefully
this will get across to people in the
nfl this is good for all of us this is
gonna make for a better league uh when i
go back to 1996 i can tell you i got
criticized i got killed in the tampa
media
lovey smith who is that where is he from
herm edwards he's not coaching in the
league we need some experience i hired
mike tomlin when he was 29 years old
where where did he come from university
of cincinnati nobody was on these guys
when
you could see they were talented and
when they got in and got a chance to
show what they could do it was just a
couple of years when everybody was
beating down the door trying to get
these guys
but getting that opportunity and getting
people to say you know what let's think
outside the box let's get away from
people we think are candidates and give
some people an opportunity who are
really bright and let's see what they
can do and hopefully this will help that
mike i appreciate you saying what you're
saying and coach explaining it even more
it gives me a better understanding yeah
i have some underlining feelings because
i just don't think that we're less than
i get tired of people thinking that
because we're black men that we're less
than we work hard we have knowledge
we're smart we study we prepare we do
all those different things but i
appreciate that perspective because from
both of you guys because it gave me
something different to look at thank you
and rod and rodney i i think the most
important thing and let's not get too
far away from where we were as a country
in may
the number one thing we need to do is
listen right we need to listen and
understand more and by you expressing
how you feel about it helps me
understand it better and see it better
so the most important thing we can all
do we don't have to all agree but at
least if we listen and understand i know
how you feel about it i understand how
people feel marginalized that you're uh
a female or an african-american or of
this race or this gender or anything
else so we have to have one of you in
the group no you want to be there
because of your merits and your talents
and your abilities so it's a difficult
line but it's it's opportunity and if
the door of opportunity opens i have a
friend who is a second generation in
sports media who said
my last name opened the door for me
there's no doubt about it but it's my
responsibility to keep the door open to
walk through that door and to succeed
and open the door for people behind me
and i love that because that's this
opportunity is for a lot of folks mike
florian i'll give you the last word on
this before we move back to the field
well i think back to 2002 when the nfl
passed the rooney rule under threat of
litigation from the late johnny cochran
and cyrus mary and
that worked at least that effort worked
to get the rooney rule passed because it
was so bad and it was so much worse then
than now but 18 years later it really
isn't in the grand scheme of things all
that much better so the league doing
what it has to do to try to improve the
pipeline and i really do think that's
the key guys it's the pipeline the more
candidates in the pipeline the more that
naturally the best will rise to the top
regardless of skin color regardless of
background regardless of anything that
pipeline just needs to be more robust
and we've seen that coaching fellowships
play coaches who come to training camps
to learn to be around the nfl then go
back to their college jobs hopefully all
of this continues to get it forward to a
better and a more equitable place
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports